звернення до світової спільноти щоби
засудити Московську федерацію як держави
терориста вигнати її з організації
об'єднаних націй це все є дуже позитивні
гарні ініціативи Але чому українська
держава продовжує підтримувати
терористів і їх посіпак всередині
Української держави що я маю на увазі ми
всі разом заборонили діяльність про
московських ми всі разом проголосували
заборону про московських політичних сил
але в результаті депутати які були
обрані від цих партій спосіб нісінько
сидів собі сидять у радах різних рівнів
але що більше займається підривною
антидержавницької діяльності зокрема Я
маю на увазі присутньо тут у Верховній
Раді п'яту колону яка Відповідальна за
Московську агресію і московське
вторгнення так чомусь Вони не притягнуті
до відповідальності не позбавлені
мандатів а виявляється з фракції
монобільшості за словами керівників
фракції у них конструктивна співпраця
Перепрошую я це лице не співпраця
тотальний маразм на місцевих рівнях ми
маємо ситуацію коли депутати про
московських партій блокують процеси
декомунізації де колонізації підтримують
усі московські наративи і спокійнісінько
почуваються але я не дарма згадую також
сьогодні про церкву у цій залі не тільки
було
у цій залі було в 2018 році
проголосовано законопроект який вимагає
Московську церкву називати московською а
не Українська Православна Церква якогось
там патріархату На жаль цей законопроект
чотири роки уже заблокований
заблокований на рівні Конституційного
Суду хоча це питання мало бути
розглянуто протягом чотирьох місяців
тому ми вимагаємо консолідованої позиції
парламенту і української держави за
якраз від народу ця позиція є що до того
щоб ми як найшвидше розблокували
законопроект щоб Московська церква була
чітко названа московською і щоби люди
які ще ходять до цієї церкви ну розуміли
що вони підтримують церкву країни
агресора а їхній пожертви по суті ідуть
на фінансування агресії України і
вбивства українців в московською
Федерацією і так само ми вимагаємо що ви
якнайшвидше були проголосовані
законопроекти які позбавлять Московську
церкву її власності в Україні тому що
вони сьогодні далі про- продовжують
доносити на українських військових вони
продовжують сіяти про Московський
наративи і якщо їх не зупиняти зараз то
в результаті ми можемо отримати ситуацію
з приятливу для повернення Московського
впливу в Україні тому я прошу коли ми
звертаємося до наших закордонних колег
засудити Московську федерацію Давайте ми
очистимо Україну від п'ятої колони яка
тут щось намагається
горнятати